This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,|||这是 IHeart 播客。绝对真人。在《Look Back At It》播客节目中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。对流我来说，84年很重要。我是 Sam J。我是 Alex English。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代一样。84 年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 Outer 上收听 look back at it。My Heart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.|||嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？您正在收听由您最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但您正在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。多少男人穿着西装或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你需要这样做，在 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcast 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Ranjini.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Ranjini.|||2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你在销售中伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个经历过同样事情的人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·兰吉尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.|||我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.|||我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一边成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听 2%。那是 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方的 TWA%。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们讨论 20 多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理学的意义。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Now, before we get into it, I have a really,
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Now, before we get into it, I have a really,|||大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里参加另一集的节目，当然，我们要剖析 20 多岁的心理学。现在，在我们深入探讨之前，我有一个非常，
really cool announcement. We have just launched our first ever line of notebooks, the perfect companion to the podcast. If you want to take notes while you listen to this episode, if you want to journal about what you're discovering about yourself, what you're learning, these notebooks are perfect. They were done in collaboration with an incredible Bristol-based illustrator called Rosie Pink.
really cool announcement. We have just launched our first ever line of notebooks, the perfect companion to the podcast. If you want to take notes while you listen to this episode, if you want to journal about what you're discovering about yourself, what you're learning, these notebooks are perfect. They were done in collaboration with an incredible Bristol-based illustrator called Rosie Pink.|||非常酷的公告。我们刚刚推出了我们的第一系列笔记本，这是播客的完美伴侣。如果您想在听这集时做笔记，如果您想写下您对自己的发现、您正在学习的内容的日记，这些笔记本是完美的。它们是与一位来自布里斯托尔的出色插画家 Rosie Pink 合作完成的。
If you follow me on Instagram, you will know that I have been a fan of her work for many, many years. And we finally got the opportunity to collaborate and to create something that we really, truly love. You guys are always asking me for ways that you can support the podcast. I want to keep this completely free, but if you do feel called to do so, and if you are in need of a notebook, which you can never have too many of, please see the link in the episode description or on our Shopify account. I'm so excited for this. It's like super high quality. Of course, we weren't going to
If you follow me on Instagram, you will know that I have been a fan of her work for many, many years. And we finally got the opportunity to collaborate and to create something that we really, truly love. You guys are always asking me for ways that you can support the podcast. I want to keep this completely free, but if you do feel called to do so, and if you are in need of a notebook, which you can never have too many of, please see the link in the episode description or on our Shopify account. I'm so excited for this. It's like super high quality. Of course, we weren't going to|||如果你在 Instagram 上关注我，你就会知道我多年来一直是她作品的粉丝。我们终于有机会合作并创造出我们真正喜爱的东西。你们总是问我有什么方法可以支持播客。我想让它完全免费，但如果你确实觉得自己有义务这样做，并且如果你需要一个笔记本（你永远不会嫌多），请查看剧集描述中的链接或我们的 Shopify 帐户。我对此感到非常兴奋。就像超级高质量一样。当然，我们不会
make something terrible that you're going to spend your good old fashioned money on. So how a look, see if they perk your interest. They're gorgeous, they are well made and they were made with love. So now let's get into the episode. One of the inevitable aspects of this decade, I think of simply being human, is that there will come a time when we consciously and deliberately need to separate and move on from somebody that we once loved. Whether that is a friend or an ex, somebody else in our lives a family member for example i think it is one of those really sad universal truths of kind of humanity not all relationships are meant to last not all of them can kind of withstand the test of time and in order for us to really truly move on sometimes we do need a total break from that person
make something terrible that you're going to spend your good old fashioned money on. So how a look, see if they perk your interest. They're gorgeous, they are well made and they were made with love. So now let's get into the episode. One of the inevitable aspects of this decade, I think of simply being human, is that there will come a time when we consciously and deliberately need to separate and move on from somebody that we once loved. Whether that is a friend or an ex, somebody else in our lives a family member for example i think it is one of those really sad universal truths of kind of humanity not all relationships are meant to last not all of them can kind of withstand the test of time and in order for us to really truly move on sometimes we do need a total break from that person|||做出让你花光老本的糟糕东西。所以看一眼，看看它们是否激起了你的兴趣。它们很华丽，制作精良，并且是用爱制作的。现在让我们进入正题。这个十年的不可避免的方面之一，我认为仅仅是作为一个人，那就是总会有一天，我们需要有意识地、刻意地与我们曾经爱过的人分开并继续前进。无论是朋友还是前任，我们生活中的其他人，例如家庭成员，我认为这是人类那种真正悲伤的普遍真理之一，并非所有的关系都注定要持久，并非所有关系都能经受住时间的考验，为了让我们真正真正地继续前进，有时我们确实需要与那个人彻底决裂。
to fully heal and to finally process what we experienced Relationships they break, they fall apart. And I think whilst we may have imagined that this person would have been in our life forever, maybe we always knew it was going to end this way, the conclusion of a relationship is a really messy and confusing time. And sometimes the only way forward, the only way to stop getting drawn back in, to stop compulsively checking on them to allow yourself closure,
to fully heal and to finally process what we experienced Relationships they break, they fall apart. And I think whilst we may have imagined that this person would have been in our life forever, maybe we always knew it was going to end this way, the conclusion of a relationship is a really messy and confusing time. And sometimes the only way forward, the only way to stop getting drawn back in, to stop compulsively checking on them to allow yourself closure,|||以完全治愈并最终处理我们的经历 关系打破，它们崩溃了。我想，虽然我们可能想象过这个人会永远留在我们的生活中，也许我们一直都知道它会以这种方式结束，但一段关系的结束是一个非常混乱和混淆的时期。有时，唯一的出路，唯一停止被拉回来、停止强迫性地检查他们以允许自己闭幕的方法，
is to go no contact. No contact, this method of separating ourselves and cutting off all kind of communication with somebody post breakup, post argument, post conflict. It's really seen arise in popularity and arise in supporters. And I want to talk about it today. What exactly is no contact? What are the rules?
is to go no contact. No contact, this method of separating ourselves and cutting off all kind of communication with somebody post breakup, post argument, post conflict. It's really seen arise in popularity and arise in supporters. And I want to talk about it today. What exactly is no contact? What are the rules?|||就是失联。不联系，这种在分手、争吵、冲突后将自己与某人隔离并切断所有形式沟通的方法。它确实越来越受欢迎，支持者也越来越多。我今天想谈谈这个。究竟什么是“不联系”？规则是什么？
How does it actually work? Why is it so effective? Why is it necessary? And how can we actually stay committed to how, I guess, commitment to seeing this person fade from our lives and fade from our future? It's a really sad and scary reality that, you know, there might come a time where this person just can't be the person that we want them to be and we do need to let ourselves and let them move on. So this is kind of your ultimate guide to no contact, how it works, why it works, and how you, can implement it. Now I will say some people don't necessarily agree with me when I say that no contact is the answer. In fact, I think I would have previously disagreed with myself. You know,
How does it actually work? Why is it so effective? Why is it necessary? And how can we actually stay committed to how, I guess, commitment to seeing this person fade from our lives and fade from our future? It's a really sad and scary reality that, you know, there might come a time where this person just can't be the person that we want them to be and we do need to let ourselves and let them move on. So this is kind of your ultimate guide to no contact, how it works, why it works, and how you, can implement it. Now I will say some people don't necessarily agree with me when I say that no contact is the answer. In fact, I think I would have previously disagreed with myself. You know,|||它是如何运作的？为什么这么有效？为什么有必要？我们怎样才能真正致力于如何，我想，致力于看到这个人从我们的生活中淡出并从我们的未来中淡出？这是一个非常悲伤和可怕的现实，你知道，可能有一天这个人根本不能成为我们希望他们成为的人，我们确实需要让我们自己和他们继续前进。所以这可以说是你关于不联系的终极指南，它是如何运作的，为什么它起作用，以及你如何能够实施它。现在我要说的是，当我说是时候不联系是答案时，有些人不一定同意我的观点。事实上，我想我以前会不同意我自己的观点。你知道，
if you had asked me two years ago whether you could stay in touch with an ex or repair a severely broken bond with a friend, I would have said yes. I would have said that that is the mature thing to do, that it showed growth. I even did an episode with my ex-boyfriend a few years back. It sounds insane. It's still up if you want to go and find it. But we essentially discussed how we were still friends, how we were so mature for maintaining the relationship.
if you had asked me two years ago whether you could stay in touch with an ex or repair a severely broken bond with a friend, I would have said yes. I would have said that that is the mature thing to do, that it showed growth. I even did an episode with my ex-boyfriend a few years back. It sounds insane. It's still up if you want to go and find it. But we essentially discussed how we were still friends, how we were so mature for maintaining the relationship.|||如果你在两年前问我是否可以与前任保持联系或修复与朋友严重破裂的纽带，我会说是的。我会说那是成熟的做法，它显示了成长。几年前，我甚至和我的前男友一起拍了一集。这听起来太疯狂了。如果你想去找它，它仍然在线。但我们本质上讨论了我们如何仍然是朋友，我们如何为维持这种关系而如此成熟。
Surprise, surprise, we no longer are. And I think no contact was the way that that inevitably came to an end. Different things obviously work for different people. but I think with relationships and with X's in particular, one of the reasons that we stay in touch, that we don't go no contact, is because we aren't actually completely ready to move on, even if we think that we are.
Surprise, surprise, we no longer are. And I think no contact was the way that that inevitably came to an end. Different things obviously work for different people. but I think with relationships and with X's in particular, one of the reasons that we stay in touch, that we don't go no contact, is because we aren't actually completely ready to move on, even if we think that we are.|||惊不惊喜，意不意外，我们不再是了。我认为不联系是不可避免地走向终结的方式。不同的事情显然对不同的人有用。但我认为对于人际关系，尤其是前任，我们保持联系、不失联的原因之一，是因为我们其实并没有完全准备好继续前进，即使我们认为我们已经准备好了。
This person is kind of always there. They're always ready to come back into our lives. We are always ready to let them back in our lives because they remain an option to us. But I think when we allow these people who, we know should not be, you know, that they are not going to create a fulfilling future for us, that they just aren't right for us. They've caused us pain. When we allow them to stay in our lives, they take up valuable mental, social, physical space. I think the same goes for friendships that have
This person is kind of always there. They're always ready to come back into our lives. We are always ready to let them back in our lives because they remain an option to us. But I think when we allow these people who, we know should not be, you know, that they are not going to create a fulfilling future for us, that they just aren't right for us. They've caused us pain. When we allow them to stay in our lives, they take up valuable mental, social, physical space. I think the same goes for friendships that have|||这个人总是在那里。他们随时准备回到我们的生活中。我们随时准备让他们回到我们的生活中，因为他们对我们来说仍然是一个选择。但我认为，当我们允许这些人时，我们知道不应该，你知道，他们不会为我们创造一个充实的未来，他们只是不适合我们。他们给我们造成了痛苦。当我们允许他们留在我们的生活中时，他们会占用宝贵的精神、社交、物理空间。我认为同样的道理也适用于
turned sour. When we keep giving people second chances, when we hope that they will change, when we let them overstep boundaries, eventually we do have to make a tough decision and hopefully a permanent one to no longer allow them access to us. I don't think that it's an easy or a light decision to come by. I don't think that personally I'm somebody who could sit here and say, if you have any kind of conflict or disagreement with somebody, cut them out. They're not good for you because that is quite an unhealthy and unsustainable thing to do. But I think personally, the more that I've matured and grown, the more that I've understood that, especially in the aftermath of a really intense, like, serious breakup, one of the only ways to find closure is to see this person exit
turned sour. When we keep giving people second chances, when we hope that they will change, when we let them overstep boundaries, eventually we do have to make a tough decision and hopefully a permanent one to no longer allow them access to us. I don't think that it's an easy or a light decision to come by. I don't think that personally I'm somebody who could sit here and say, if you have any kind of conflict or disagreement with somebody, cut them out. They're not good for you because that is quite an unhealthy and unsustainable thing to do. But I think personally, the more that I've matured and grown, the more that I've understood that, especially in the aftermath of a really intense, like, serious breakup, one of the only ways to find closure is to see this person exit|||变味了。当我们不断给人们第二次机会时，当我们希望他们改变时，当我们让他们越过界限时，最终我们确实必须做出艰难的决定，最好是永久性的决定，不再让他们接近我们。我认为这不是一个容易或轻率的决定。我不认为我个人可以坐在那里说，如果你与某人有任何冲突或分歧，就把他们切断。他们对你不好，因为这是一件非常不健康且不可持续的事情。但我个人认为，我越成熟和成长，我就越理解，尤其是在经历了一场非常激烈、认真的分手之后，找到闭幕的唯一途径之一就是看到这个人退出
your life permanently and for you to be committed to that decision. The more that I've kind of realized that no contact, when it's possible, when there are no kids or pets involved, or you're not working together, whatever it is, no contact is the best option. And, a lot of the psychology kind of proves it as well. And it doesn't just prove that it's maybe just good for you on an emotional level, but it also proves that it actually lessens the time that it's going to take for you to move on and to be open to new people entering your lives, whether that is platonically or romantically. So let's talk about it today. Let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take
your life permanently and for you to be committed to that decision. The more that I've kind of realized that no contact, when it's possible, when there are no kids or pets involved, or you're not working together, whatever it is, no contact is the best option. And, a lot of the psychology kind of proves it as well. And it doesn't just prove that it's maybe just good for you on an emotional level, but it also proves that it actually lessens the time that it's going to take for you to move on and to be open to new people entering your lives, whether that is platonically or romantically. So let's talk about it today. Let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take|||你的生活永久地为你致力于那个决定。我越来越意识到，当有可能的时候，当没有孩子或宠物参与时，或者你没有一起工作，无论它是什么，不联系是最好的选择。而且，很多心理学也证明了这一点。它不仅证明它可能对你在情感层面上对你有好处，而且它还证明它实际上减少了你继续前进并对新进入你生活的人开放所需的时间，无论是柏拉图式还是浪漫。所以我们今天来谈谈吧。让我们进入正题。2%。那是采取行动的人数
the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.|||在有自动扶梯可用时走楼梯。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上有炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush, didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush, didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.|||我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一边成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人. 收听 2%。那是 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方的 TWO percent。你还记得 Diana Ross 在 VMA 上双击 Little Kim 的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little camp? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down,
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little camp? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down,|||乔治布什跟一个小营地有什么关系？好吧，您可以在 Look Back at it 播客中找到答案。我是 Sam J。我是 Alex English。每一期节目，我们都会在这里挑选它，剖析发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.|||并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）大谈 80 年代的快克（crack）。需要明确的是，84 对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我有一天愿意谈论快克，但只是为了让你们知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second. episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second. episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?|||我的意思是，马克，这是第二集我们讨论正确。所以我开始看到有一条贯穿线。我们现在也将艾滋病提上日程。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast. Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month,
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast. Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month,|||是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 look back at it。欢迎来到我的新播客。与我、您的主持人以及您最喜欢的治疗师 Kear Games 一起学习《Learn the Hard Way》。为了纪念心理健康意识月，
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough.
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough.|||我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多出色的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某事时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这东西。我们还在追逐它，我们不知道什么时候做得够了。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.|||因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要，还是因为你害怕而成为一个好人？因为这是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对地。这是两个不同级别的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.|||我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我和 Kear Gaines 的行列，在我的新播客《learn the hard way》中就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开您的免费 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see|||随后的家庭法庭听证会显示她的说法存在明显的矛盾。这开始了长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。你在销售中伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我测试了一次。需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到
what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.|||他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的人。格雷格，女同性恋，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted|||我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉
on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. For those of us who are unfamiliar with this method,
on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. For those of us who are unfamiliar with this method,|||涉嫌欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。对于我们这些不熟悉这种方法的人来说，
no contact is essentially what it sounds like. It involves cutting off all communication with somebody following some kind of breakdown in the relationship. Normally, that is a breakup. Something has occurred that has made you realize that the relationship is beyond repair. It could even be months, years, after the breakup where you've just realized that you are not at the point of recovery that you need to be
no contact is essentially what it sounds like. It involves cutting off all communication with somebody following some kind of breakdown in the relationship. Normally, that is a breakup. Something has occurred that has made you realize that the relationship is beyond repair. It could even be months, years, after the breakup where you've just realized that you are not at the point of recovery that you need to be|||不联系本质上就是听起来的那样。它包括在关系发生某种破裂后切断与某人的所有沟通。通常，那是分手。发生了一件事情，让你意识到这段关系已经无法修复。甚至可能是在分手几个月、几年后，你才意识到你还没有达到你需要的恢复点
because you keep letting this person back in because you are maintaining some kind of communication with them that is not letting you heal. So no contact is this kind of realization that we have that there needs to be a final and very much resolute separation from this person. Now when I say cutting off all contact. We are not just talking about, you know, avoiding running into them or blocking their number, their social media, their email. We are also talking about something that is not often included, which is preventing yourself from following up with mutual friends. I think we often tend to focus on specifically the communication between just us and this one other person. And when we limit that, we are going no contact. But the purpose of this method is to essentially allow somebody else to fade
because you keep letting this person back in because you are maintaining some kind of communication with them that is not letting you heal. So no contact is this kind of realization that we have that there needs to be a final and very much resolute separation from this person. Now when I say cutting off all contact. We are not just talking about, you know, avoiding running into them or blocking their number, their social media, their email. We are also talking about something that is not often included, which is preventing yourself from following up with mutual friends. I think we often tend to focus on specifically the communication between just us and this one other person. And when we limit that, we are going no contact. But the purpose of this method is to essentially allow somebody else to fade|||因为你不断让这个人回来，因为你与他们保持某种沟通，这让你无法治愈。因此，“不联系”就是我们意识到需要与这个人进行最后且非常坚决的分离。现在，当我谈到切断所有联系时。我们不仅在谈论，你知道，避免偶遇或屏蔽他们的号码、他们的社交媒体、他们的电子邮件。我们还在谈论一件经常不包括在内的事情，那就是阻止自己跟进共同的朋友。我认为我们往往倾向于专门关注我们和这另一个人之间的交流。当我们限制这一点时，我们就会选择失联。但这种方法的核心目的其实是让另一个人淡出
from your life in the most efficient way possible to put up that strong boundary. And when we keep asking people around us if they've heard anything, if they know what's going on in that other person's life, you know, whether they're dating anybody, whether they're sad, or they miss us, touching base with our mutual friends about their existence and their well-being and their whereabouts, I think that really defeats the purpose. It can also really undo so much of the effort that we've already put into to touch, right?
from your life in the most efficient way possible to put up that strong boundary. And when we keep asking people around us if they've heard anything, if they know what's going on in that other person's life, you- know, whether they're dating anybody, whether they're sad, or they miss us, touching base with our mutual friends about their existence and their well-being and their whereabouts, I think that really defeats the purpose. It can also really undo so much of the effort that we've already put into to touch, right?|||用尽可能有效的方式离开你的生活，以建立起坚固的界限。当我们不断问周围的人他们是否听到任何消息，他们是否知道另一个人生活中发生了什么，你知道，无论是谁在约会，他们是否悲伤，或者他们是否想念我们，与我们共同的朋友联系关于他们的存在、他们的福祉和他们的行踪，我认为这真的违背了初衷。这也确实会抹杀我们为触碰已经付出的很多努力，对吧？
we've done all the other things correctly. We don't have any direct contact with this person, but that indirect contact still counts. It still activates all those old memories. It still keeps the memory of this person very much active and present in your life. That doesn't mean that you, of course, have to remove anybody that has any connection to this person, otherwise you risk falling into temptation.
we've done all the other things correctly. We don't have any direct contact with this person, but that indirect contact still counts. It still activates all those old memories. It still keeps the memory of this person very much active and present in your life. That doesn't mean that you, of course, have to remove anybody that has any connection to this person, otherwise you risk falling into temptation.|||我们把其他事情都做对了。我们与这个人没有任何直接接触，但间接接触仍然算数。它仍然会激活所有这些旧记忆。它仍然让这个人的记忆在你的生活中非常活跃和存在。这并不意味着你当然必须删除任何与这个人有任何联系的人，否则你会有陷入诱惑的危险。
more so that I think we need to be conscious of the ways that we are replacing the direct contact that we crave with our ex, with our old friend. We're replacing that direct contact with secondary contact and it's still fulfilling that main function and purpose, which is that we feel connected to them in some way. It is such a crucial element that I think we often forget, myself included at times. I remember going like no contact with an ex maybe three years back. But I remained very much attached and I really clung on to the friendships that I had with his housemates and the friends that we had made together.
more so that I think we need to be conscious of the ways that we are replacing the direct contact that we crave with our ex, with our old friend. We're replacing that direct contact with secondary contact and it's still fulfilling that main function and purpose, which is that we feel connected to them in some way. It is such a crucial element that I think we often forget, myself included at times. I remember going like no contact with an ex maybe three years back. But I remember very much attached and I really clung on to the friendships that I had with his housemates and the friends that we had made together.|||更是因为我认为我们需要意识到我们正在用什么方式来取代我们与前任、老朋友所渴望的直接接触。我们正在用二次接触来取代这种直接接触，它仍然在履行其主要功能和目的，即我们在某种程度上感到与他们有联系。这是一个如此关键的要素，我认为我们经常忘记，有时包括我自己。我记得大约三年前和一个前任断了联系。但我记得非常执着，我真的很执着于我和他的室友以及我们一起结交的朋友之间的友谊。
And I eventually really realized that I was using a lot of our interactions to speak about him rather than actually focus on the other person and the friendship that we had built independent of my ex. One thing that I think we know about no contact is that it really, requires a whole lot of commitment. It is not for the faint-hearted. Somebody actually said it to me this way the other day. No contact involves treating this other person as if they've died. That is how intense it can be and the level of discipline that it can take. You kind of have to imagine that even if you wanted to reach out, you couldn't. And I also think that this way of seeing things,
And I eventually really realized that I was using a lot of our interactions to speak about him rather than actually focus on the other person and the friendship that we had built independent of my ex. One thing that I think we know about no contact is that it really, requires a whole lot of commitment. It is not for the faint-hearted. Somebody actually said it to me this way the other day. No contact involves treating this other person as if they've died. That is how intense it can be and the level of discipline that it can take. You kind of have to imagine that even if you wanted to reach out, you couldn't. And I also think that this way of seeing things,|||我最终真正意识到，我利用我们的很多互动来谈论他，而不是真正关注另一个人以及我们独立于我的前任建立的友谊。关于失联，我认为我们都知道的一件事是，它确实需要大量的承诺。这不是给胆小鬼准备的。前几天有人实际上对我说过这样的话。不联系包括把对方当成已经死了一样对待。这就是它的强烈程度以及它所需的纪律水平。你有点得想象，即使你想联系，你也做不到。我也认为这种看问题的方式，
there is absolutely no possibility of communicating going forward helps us justify our grief as well. It stops us from feeling a lot of disenfranchised grief, that we shouldn't be feeling sad, that we should be over it by now, that this isn't a big deal. When we treat it like, no, this person is forever out of my life, we are allowed to really feel the pain that I think we should be feeling at the end of any relationship. The level, though, of discipline and control that that takes and knowing how finite that decision will probably be is what keeps a lot of us from ever thinking that we could do it, from trying every other possible solution, trying to be friends before we finally get to that
there is absolutely no possibility of communicating going forward helps us justify our grief as well. It stops us from feeling a lot of disenfranchised grief, that we shouldn't be feeling sad, that we should be over it by now, that this isn't a big deal. When we treat it like, no, this person is forever out of my life, we are allowed to really feel the pain that I think we should be feeling at the end of any relationship. The level, though, of discipline and control that that takes and knowing how finite that decision will probably be is what keeps a lot of us from ever thinking that we could do it, from trying every other possible solution, trying to be friends before we finally get to that|||未来绝对不可能沟通，这也助于我们证明我们的悲伤是正当的。它阻止我们感受到很多被剥夺权利的悲伤，我们不应该感到悲伤，我们现在应该克服它，这没什么大不了的。当我们把它当作“不，这个人永远走出了我的生活”来对待时，我们被允许真正感受到我认为在任何关系结束时我们都应该感到的痛苦。然而，这所需的纪律和控制水平，以及知道这个决定可能有多有限，正是阻止我们许多人认为我们可以做到这一点的原因，从尝试所有其他可能的解决方案，尝试做朋友，直到我们最终达到这一点。
point where we know that there is no other option. I also think that it's super normal sometimes to go back and forth, right? to unblock their number and then block it again, to really fight the urge to reach out and then slip up and have to reinstitute that war between you two, human relationships, especially ones that are so deep and passionate and emotional that they would require this amount of drastic action. They're complicated and they contain a lot of contradictory emotions. Anger one minute. Nostalgia the next. Grief one day and joy and gratitude. tomorrow. So it can be very hard to stay strong. It can be very hard to be committed to this decision
point where we know that there is no other option. I also think that it's super normal sometimes to go back and forth, right? to unblock their number and then block it again, to really fight the urge to reach out and then slip up and have to reinstitute that war between you two, human relationships, especially ones that are so deep and passionate and emotional that they would require this amount of drastic action. They're complicated and they contain a lot of contradictory emotions. Anger one minute. Nostalgia the next. Grief one day and joy and gratitude. tomorrow. So it can be very hard to stay strong. It can be very hard to be committed to this decision|||我们知道别无选择的时候。我也觉得有时候反反复复超级正常，对吧？解封他们的号码然后再屏蔽，真正与伸出援手的冲动作斗争，然后失误，不得不重新建立你们两个之间的战争，人际关系，尤其是那些如此深刻、充满激情和情感以至于需要这种激进行动的人。它们很复杂，包含许多相互矛盾的情绪。一分钟生气。接下来的怀旧。一天的悲伤和喜悦与感激。明天。所以要保持坚强是非常困难的。要致力于这个决定是非常困难的
because how you're feeling about the situation right now might not be how you're feeling about it tomorrow when you miss this person beyond belief, beyond anything that you have felt. But personally, I do think that this period of no contact is almost necessary to completely heal in mend. It provides us with the emotional, mental, social, and importantly, the physical space to A, actually process our experience with them, the good and the bad, and B, come to terms with the reality that this person is no longer going to be part of our life in the same way. And that is what it's going to be going forward. That is something that we cannot change. If we have decided that we cannot be in a relationship with this person, if they've decided it for us, part of that future, that future
because how you're feeling about the situation right now might not be how you're feeling about it tomorrow when you miss this person beyond belief, beyond anything that you have felt. But personally, I do think that this period of no contact is almost necessary to completely heal in mend. It provides us with the emotional, mental, social, and importantly, the physical space to A, actually process our experience with them, the good and the bad, and B, come to terms with the reality that this person is no longer going to be part of our life in the same way. And that is what it's going to be going forward. That is something that we cannot change. If we have decided that we cannot be in a relationship with this person, if they've decided it for us, part of that future, that future|||因为你现在对这种情况的感觉可能和你明天想念这个人时的感觉不一样，超出了你的想象，超出了你的任何感受。但我个人认为，为了彻底治愈，这段不联系的时期几乎是必要的。它为我们提供了情感、心理、社交以及最重要的身体空间，A，实际处理我们与他们的经历，好的和坏的，B，接受这样一个现实，即这个人将不再是以同样的方式成为我们生活的一部分。这就是未来的发展方向。这是我们无法改变的。如果我们已经决定不能与这个人建立关系，如果他们为我们做了决定，那么未来的一部分，那个未来
path that we are now on is, you know, a path towards never speaking again. And I think no contact gets us comfortable with that reality a lot quicker. Here's kind of how I like to see it and how I've justified it actually to myself in the past. The end of a relationship is always going to hurt. the pain of detaching from someone is going to be intense no matter which way you square it. But that pain can exist for a longer period of time for a year or more at like 50% intensity or it can exist at 100% intensity but only for a couple of months. It really depends on whether you are ready to heal or in. endure the separation over a longer timeline or whether you are ready to bite the bullet.
path that we are now on is, you know, a path towards never speaking again. And I think no contact gets us comfortable with that reality a lot quicker. Here's kind of how I like to see it and how I've justified it actually to myself in the past. The end of a relationship is always going to hurt. the pain of detaching from someone is going to be intense no matter which way you square it. But that pain can exist for a longer period of time for a year or more at like 50% intensity or it can exist at 100% intensity but only for a couple of months. It really depends on whether you are ready to heal or in. endure the separation over a longer timeline or whether you are ready to bite the bullet.|||我们现在所走的道路，你知道，是一条永远不再说话的道路。我认为不联系让我们更快地适应这个现实。这就是我喜欢看待它的方式，以及我过去如何向自己证明这一点。一段关系的结束总是会受伤。无论你如何看待，与某人脱离的痛苦都是剧烈的。但这种痛苦可能会存在更长的时间，持续一年或更长时间，强度约为 50%，或者它可能以 100% 的强度存在，但只持续几个月。这 realmente 取决于您是准备好治愈还是在。在更长的时间线内忍受分离，还是你准备好咬紧牙关。
And yes, experience the intensity of all of that grief, all of that rage, all of that recovery at once rather than keeping yourself still kind of attached to them just because it makes it feel easier in the moment. So my other argument for no contact is that it also stops us from sliding back into the relationship during that very vulnerable period where we do just genuinely want somebody. And when that somebody is somebody that we are already familiar with and that we already know and that we know is available, it's so much easier to backslide. No contact is basically you saying, no, this is an absolute decision.
And yes, experience the intensity of all of that grief, all of that rage, all of that recovery at once rather than keeping yourself still kind of attached to them just because it makes it feel easier in the moment. So my other argument for no contact is that it also stops us from sliding back into the relationship during that very vulnerable period where we do just genuinely want somebody. And when that somebody is somebody that we are already familiar with and that we already know and that we know is available, it's so much easier to backslide. No contact is basically you saying, no, this is an absolute decision.|||是的，一次性体验所有悲伤、所有愤怒、所有恢复的强度，而不是让自己仍然有点依恋他们，只是因为这让它在当下感觉更容易。所以我支持不联系的另一个论点是，它也阻止我们在那个非常脆弱的时期滑回关系中，在这个时期我们确实真心想要某人。当那个某人是我们已经熟悉且已经认识并且知道有空的人时，倒退就容易得多了。不联系基本上就是你在说，不，这是一个绝对的决定。
And I think it's a lot harder for you to turn around and be like, no, just kidding, I change my mind. because you can't really justify that to your past version of yourself. You can't justify that to your current version of yourself who knows in the back of their mind that there was a reason that we decided to be this drastic about our efforts. So the final reason I think that no contact is powerful is because it lets us provide ourselves with closure
And I think it's a lot harder for you to turn around and be like, no, just kidding, I change my mind. because you can't really justify that to your past version of yourself. You can't justify that to your current version of yourself who knows in the back of their mind that there was a reason that we decided to be this drastic about our efforts. So the final reason I think that no contact is powerful is because it lets us provide ourselves with closure|||而且我认为你很难转身说，不，开玩笑的，我改变主意了。因为你无法向过去的自己证明这一点。你无法向现在的自己证明这一点，他们内心深处知道我们决定在努力上如此激进是有原因的。因此，我认为不联系之所以强大的最后一个原因是因为它让我们能够为自己提供闭幕式
rather than waiting on somebody else to do it for us. it lets us essentially take matters into our own hands. If this person is still stringing you along, you know, hitting you up every now and again, if you're still waiting for a message or relying on them when you know that you can't, no contact gives you the power to close that chapter for yourself. It is such a decisive and strong way of saying, I'm done. I'm over this. Like this is done.
rather than waiting on somebody else to do it for us. it lets us essentially take matters into our own hands. If this person is still stringing you along, you know, hitting you up every now and again, if you're still waiting for a message or relying on them when you know that you can't, no contact gives you the power to close that chapter for yourself. It is such a decisive and strong way of saying, I'm done. I'm over this. Like this is done.|||而不是等着别人替我们做这件事。它基本上让我们把事情掌握在自己手中。如果这个人仍然在拖着你，你知道，时不时地联系你，如果你还在等待消息或者在明知不能的情况下依赖他们，不联系赋予了你自己结束那一章的力量。这是一种如此果断和强烈的方式，表达了我受够了。我结束了。就像这已经结束了一样。
And I have made that decision for both of us. I'm putting all of the memories, our bond, our love. That is now in the past and my future is just kind of me, myself and I, and I'm going to move forward without you beside me. I think it's also especially powerful for breaking really painful and toxic cycles of like distancing ourselves for a couple of weeks and then going back. Because no contact is quite permanent, right? It's really saying enough is enough.
And I have made that decision for both of us. I'm putting all of the memories, our bond, our love. That is now in the past and my future is just kind of me, myself and I, and I'm going to move forward without you beside me. I think it's also especially powerful for breaking really painful and toxic cycles of like distancing ourselves for a couple of weeks and then going back. Because no contact is quite permanent, right? It really saying enough is enough.|||我已经为我们两个人做出了这个决定。我把所有的记忆、我们的羁绊、我们的爱都抛诸脑后。那已经成为了过去，我的未来就是我、我自己和我，我将在没有你的陪伴下前进。我认为打破非常痛苦和有毒的循环也特别有力，比如疏远几周然后又回去。因为不联系是相当永久的，对吧？它真的说够了就是够了。
That's it. I'm doing what is best for me. It is a hard boundary rather than like a soft permission slip of like maybe if you like text me at 2am, this could be a thing. It's like no, you can't even text me. This is not even a remote possibility. So why does this work? So many people, including myself, obviously are such huge proponents of this method for really
That's it. I'm doing what is best for me. It is a hard boundary rather than like a soft permission slip of like maybe if you like text me at 2am, this could be a thing. It's like no, you can't even text me. This is not even a remote possibility. So why does this work? So many people, including myself, obviously are such huge proponents of this method for really|||就这样。我在做对我最好的事。这是一个硬边界，而不是像软许可单那样，也许如果你喜欢在凌晨 2 点给我发短信，这可能会是一回事。这就像不，你甚至不能给我发短信。这甚至都不是遥远的可能性。那为什么这管用呢？很多人，包括我自己，显然都是这种方法的坚定支持者，
detaching and finally ending things, there has to be some evidence for it. There has to be more than just anecdotal evidence that this is effective and efficient. Of course, I had to find the science for you guys. Couldn't just give you empty advice without the psychology. So to understand this, we really need to comprehend the psychology and the biology of attachment. And it starts with how we initially fell in love with this person. So when we begin to get close to someone, especially intimately, whether that is emotional, physical intimacy, even like intellectual intimacy, our brain releases oxytocin. This is known as the love or the bonding hormone.
detaching and finally ending things, there has to be some evidence for it. There has to be more than just anecdotal evidence that this is effective and efficient. Of course, I had to find the science for you guys. Couldn't just give you empty advice without the psychology. So to understand this, we really need to comprehend the psychology and the biology of attachment. And it starts with how we initially fell in love with this person. So when we begin to get close to someone, especially intimately, whether that is emotional, physical intimacy, even like intellectual intimacy, our brain releases oxytocin. This is known as the love or the bonding hormone.|||超然并最终结束事情，必须有一些证据。必须有不仅仅是轶事证据证明这是有效和高效的。当然，我必须为你们寻找科学依据。不能只给你没有心理学的空洞建议。所以要理解这一点，我们真的需要理解依恋的心理学和生物学。它始于我们最初是如何爱上这个人的。因此，当我们开始接近某人时，尤其是亲密接触时，无论是情感上的、身体上的亲密，甚至是智力上的亲密，我们的大脑都会释放催产素。这被称为爱或结合荷尔蒙。
And the function of this hormone is to promote trust, to promote safety, security. And it's really crucial. It is like the biological building block for, asserting and creating and constructing relationships. So it's kind of what binds a lot of us together. The other thing to know about oxytocin is that it is often released in tandem and parallel to other hormones and neurotransmitters that we associate with pleasure and happiness and love. I'm talking about dopamine and serotonin, of course the two famous ones.
And the function of this hormone is to promote trust, to promote safety, security. And it's really crucial. It is like the biological building block for, asserting and creating and constructing relationships. So it's kind of what binds a lot of us together. The other thing to know about oxytocin is that it is often released in tandem and parallel to other hormones and neurotransmitters that we associate with pleasure and happiness and love. I'm talking about dopamine and serotonin, of course the two famous ones.|||这种荷尔蒙的作用是促进信任，促进安全，安全感。这真的很关键。它就像生物学上的构建块，用于断言、创建和构建关系。所以这就是把我们很多人绑在一起的东西。关于催产素，另一件需要了解的事情是，它通常与我们与快乐、幸福和爱相关的其他荷尔蒙和神经递质串联并平行释放。我说的是多巴胺和血清素，当然是两个著名的。
There have been some studies, including one published in 2017. that suggests that the chemical reaction produced by this cocktail of hormones and chemicals and neurotransmitters that is associated with falling in love is a lot similar to the same chemical process that occurs when we become addicted to a substance. It's thrilling. It's exhilarating. It consumes our rational brain and it gets us hooked. Not only is oxytocin just a really nice.
There have been some studies, including one published in 2017. that suggests that the chemical reaction produced by this cocktail of hormones and chemicals and neurotransmitters that is associated with falling in love is a lot similar to the same chemical process that occurs when we become addicted to a substance. It's thrilling. It's exhilarating. It consumes our rational brain and it gets us hooked. Not only is oxytocin just a really nice.|||有一些研究，包括 2017 年发表的一项研究。这表明由这种与坠入爱河相关的荷尔蒙、化学物质和神经递质鸡尾酒产生的化学反应与我们对某种物质上瘾时发生相的化学过程非常相似。太惊险了。这是令人振奋的。它消耗了我们理性的大脑，让我们上瘾。催产素不仅是一种非常好的东西。
nice hormone to experience. Not only does it make us feel really good, it is also habit forming. Because it is such a pleasurable experience, when the release of oxytocin is paired with some event or stimuli or a person like an ex-boyfriend, an ex-girlfriend, an ex-partner, we begin to associate this person with all of those amazing feelings that we are chasing. And so when we want a hit of that same great feeling, we seek them out. They kind of become like our drug dealer. All of this is what contributes to the intensity of the early stages of a relationship, but also like the comfort and the warmth of love. Now, when things start to turn sour, it is not like that love fades overnight. What we start to see is, I think, a general gradual decline, but also an unstable association between
nice hormone to experience. Not only does it make us feel really good, it is also habit forming. Because it is such a pleasurable experience, when the release of oxytocin is paired with some event or stimuli or a person like an ex-boyfriend, an ex-girlfriend, an ex-partner, we begin to associate this person with all of those amazing feelings that we are chasing. And so when we want a hit of that same great feeling, we seek them out. They kind of become like our drug dealer. All of this is what contributes to the intensity of the early stages of a relationship, but also like the comfort and the warmth of love. Now, when things start to turn sour, it is not like that love fades overnight. What we start to see is, I think, a general gradual decline, but also an unstable association between|||体验不错的荷尔蒙。它不仅让我们感觉非常好，而且还会养成习惯。因为这是一次如此愉快的经历，当催产素的释放与某些事件或刺激或一个人（例如前男友、前女友、前伴侣）配对时，我们开始将这个人与我们一直在追求的所有这些奇妙感觉联系起来。所以当我们想要那种同样美妙的感觉时，我们会去找他们。他们有点像我们的毒贩。所有这些都是促成关系早期阶段强烈程度的原因，但也喜欢爱的舒适和温暖。现在，当事情开始变坏时，这种爱并不是一夜之间消失的。我们开始看到的是，我认为，普遍的逐渐衰退，但也存在不稳定的联系
all of those nice feelings and that person, but also a new set of feelings, feelings of sadness, feelings of worry, feelings of longing, despair, unfulfillment. And so we don't really know whether this next interaction we have with them is going to produce the feelings that we want to be having, which is the feelings of love, or the feelings that make us distressed and feeling rejected and uncomfortable. Despite that, it might not be all bad, right? it's just that there is this, that the bad experiences begin to outweigh the positive ones. That's often what leads to a breakup.
all of those nice feelings and that person, but also a new set of feelings, feelings of sadness, feelings of worry, feelings of longing, despair, unfulfillment. And so we don't really know whether this next interaction we have with them is going to produce the feelings that we want to be having, which is the feelings of love, or the feelings that make us distressed and feeling rejected and uncomfortable. Despite that, it might not be all bad, right? it's just that there is this, that the bad experiences begin to outweigh the positive ones. That's often what leads to a breakup.|||所有这些美好的感觉和那个人，还有一套新的感觉，悲伤的感觉，担忧的感觉，渴望的感觉，绝望的感觉，不满足感。所以我们真的不知道我们与他们的下一次互动是否会产生我们想要的感觉，即爱的感觉，或者是让我们感到痛苦、被拒绝和不舒服的感觉。尽管如此，可能并非全是坏事，对吧？只是有这个，不好的经历开始超过积极的经历。这通常是导致分手的原因。
But it doesn't mean that there isn't still like a baseline of feeling. There is obviously going to be like a maintaining level of positive neurological and biological reactions going, you know, going about below the surface, even if they are not the majority. There is still some part of us that remains attached and bonded to this person, even if things, you know, start to become sure. shaky because we have that history. So when we break up, when we realize that this person is not for us, or when they break up with us, perhaps out of the blue, perhaps we didn't want it to occur, on a conscious level, we kind of know that things have obviously changed, like we were present for this experience, we are feeling distressed, but our neurotransmitters don't know that. Our dopamine receptors don't know that.
But it doesn't mean that there isn't still like a baseline of feeling. There is obviously going to be like a maintaining level of positive neurological and biological reactions going, you know, going about below the surface, even if they are not the majority. There is still some part of us that remains attached and bonded to this person, even if things, you know, start to become sure. shaky because we have that history. So when we break up, when we realize that this person is not for us, or when they break up with us, perhaps out of the blue, perhaps we didn't want it to occur, on a conscious level, we kind of know that things have obviously changed, like we were present for this experience, we are feeling distressed, but our neurotransmitters don't know that. Our dopamine receptors don't know that.|||但这并不意味着仍然没有类似的感觉基线。显然会有某种维持水平的积极神经和生物学反应，你知道，在表面之下发生，即使它们不是大多数。我们仍然有一部分人与这个人保持依恋和联系，即使事情，你知道，开始变得确定。动摇，因为我们有这段历史。所以当我们分手时，当我们意识到这个人不适合我们时，或者当他们和我们分手时，也许是出乎意料的，也许我们并不希望它发生，在意识层面上，我们有点知道事情显然已经改变了，就像我们经历了这段经历一样，我们感到痛苦，但我们的神经递质并不知道这一点。我们的多巴胺受体并不知道这一点。
And so it's not like the tap is suddenly turned off for our brain. It's not like the moment we've broken up with somebody or the moment a relationship has ended, our brain goes, all right, let's just shuttle that down and get them back to normal. What is happening is that there is still this urge and this craving and this desire for the kind of positive, happy chemicals and hormones that this person will, previously eliciting, but there is no longer a catalyst for those reactions because this person is no longer in your life. That is part of why breakups are so painful because the urge to stay connected to this person is still being triggered by our craving and our desire for all
And so it's not like the tap is suddenly turned off for our brain. It's not like the moment we've broken up with somebody or the moment a relationship has ended, our brain goes, all right, let's just shuttle that down and get them back to normal. What is happening is that there is still this urge and this craving and this desire for the kind of positive, happy chemicals and hormones that this person will, previously eliciting, but there is no longer a catalyst for those reactions because this person is no longer in your life. That is part of why breakups are so painful because the urge to stay connected to this person is still being triggered by our craving and our desire for all|||所以这并不像我们大脑的水龙头突然关掉一样。并不是说在我们和某人分手的那一刻或一段关系结束的那一刻，我们的大脑就会想，好吧，让我们把它关掉并让他们恢复正常。发生的事情是，对于这个人以前会引发的那种积极、快乐的化学物质和荷尔蒙，仍然有这种冲动、渴望和愿望，但这些反应不再有催化剂，因为这个人已经不在你的生活中了。这就是为什么分手如此痛苦的部分原因，因为保持与这个人联系的冲动仍然是由我们的渴望和对所有的渴望引发的
these good experiences and it's also still being triggered because we have probably formed a whole series of habits and behaviors around seeking love out from this individual. That's really why in the weeks and the early months after a breakup, after the end of a relationship, it's especially hard because we are essentially rewiring our brain to not need them anymore. Here's the catch though. Anytime you reach out, you get that spike again. When you see the mat in public, you are immediately transported back into how great it felt. And so you are getting just enough to maintain those previous. neural pathways that were kind of formed in like the error of your love story. Those connections
these good experiences and it's also still being triggered because we have probably formed a whole series of habits and behaviors around seeking love out from this individual. That's really why in the weeks and the early months after a breakup, after the end of a relationship, it's especially hard because we are essentially rewiring our brain to not need them anymore. Here's the catch though. Anytime you reach out, you get that spike again. When you see the mat in public, you are immediately transported back into how great it felt. And so you are getting just enough to maintain those previous. neural pathways that were kind of formed in like the error of your love story. Those connections|||这些美好的体验，它也仍在被触发，因为我们可能已经围绕从这个人身上寻求爱形成了一整套习惯和行为。这正是为什么在分手后、关系结束后的几周和前几个月里，这尤其困难，因为我们本质上是在重新连接我们的大脑，不再需要他们。不过，这就是问题所在。任何时候你伸出援手，你都会再次得到那个高峰。当你在公共场合看到垫子时，你会被立刻带回那种感觉有多棒的状态。所以你得到的刚好足以维持那些以前的。在你的爱情故事的错误中形成的某种神经通路。这些连接
are still maintained by those small text messages that you sometimes get. When you sleep with each other like every now and again, when you still get that, you know, Instagram DM from them and like your attention is immediately grabbed and you're immediately feeling like loved and wanted again. all of that, all of those kind of small moments in which we are yet to completely break off contact with somebody where they're still in our lives, that is keeping us hooked on them. It is what we call unpredictable reward. We don't know when we're going to get it, but by keeping those communication and contact channels and pathways open, we still expect that we're going to get something from that
are still maintained by those small text messages that you sometimes get. When you sleep with each other like every now and again, when you still get that, you know, Instagram DM from them and like your attention is immediately grabbed and you're immediately feeling like loved and wanted again. all of that, all of those kind of small moments in which we are yet to completely break off contact with somebody where they're still in our lives, that is keeping us hooked on them. It is what we call unpredictable reward. We don't know when we're going to get it, but by keeping those communication and contact channels and pathways open, we still expect that we're going to get something from that|||仍然由您有时收到的那些小短信维护。当你们每隔一段时间就上床睡觉时，当你仍然得到那个时，你知道，来自他们的 Instagram DM，就像你的注意力立刻被抓住一样，你立即再次感到被爱和需要。所有这一切，所有那些我们尚未与某人完全断绝联系的微小时刻，他们仍然在我们的生活中，这让我们对他们上瘾。这就是我们所说的不可预测的奖励。我们不知道什么时候会得到它，但通过保持这些沟通和联系渠道以及途径畅通，我们仍然期望我们能从那个地方得到一些东西
person, that there could come a time when they will, you know, light us up again, when we will get their affection, when they will want to speak to us. And so all of that emotion, all of that connection and attachment, although on a rational and very self-aware level, we know the relationship is over, by continuing to put ourselves in situations where that person is still in our life, even in a small capacity, we are not letting our brain recover. And so no contact is really the solution. here because it firstly stops temptation, but it also acts as a complete detox. It's very much a cold turkey move. I like this concept of a detox a lot when explaining this because that is
person, that there could come a time when they will, you know, light us up again, when we will get their affection, when they will want to speak to us. And so all of that emotion, all of that connection and attachment, although on a rational and very self-aware level, we know the relationship is over, by continuing to put ourselves in situations where that person is still in our life, even in a small capacity, we are not letting our brain recover. And so no contact is really the solution. here because it firstly stops temptation, but it also acts as a complete detox. It's very much a cold turkey move. I like this concept of a detox a lot when explaining this because that is|||人，可能会有一天，你知道，再次点亮我们，当我们得到他们的感情时，当他们想要和我们说话时。因此，所有这些情感、所有的联系和依恋，尽管在理性和非常自我意识的层面上，我们知道这段关系已经结束了，但通过继续把自己置于那个人仍然在我们生活中的情况下，即使是少量的，我们也没有让大脑恢复。所以不联系真的是解决方案。在这里，因为它首先阻止了诱惑，但它也起到了完全排毒的作用。这非常像一个冷火鸡的举动。在解释这一点时，我非常喜欢排毒这个概念，因为那是
essentially what is happening. This process of going no contact is a process of removing something from your mind, from your life, from your body that you no longer want present. It is this purifying cleansing process of really detoxing your life of this person and hopefully coming out cleaner, coming out better, coming out happier. You are physically removing this person from your life, right? By removing opportunities for them to stay in touch with you and for you to stay in touch with them. But you're also essentially getting used to the fact that you can feel good and you can feel
本质上正在发生的事情。这种断联的过程，就是把那些你不再希望存在于你的脑海、生活和身体里的东西剔除出去的过程。这是一个真正的、对你的生活进行排毒的净化清洁过程，希望你能以更干净、更好、更快乐的姿态走出来。你是在身体上把这个人从你的生活里移除，对吧？通过切断他们与你保持联系以及你与他们保持联系的机会。但本质上，你也是在习惯这样一个事实：你可以感觉良好，你可以感觉
happy and you can have intimate, loving feelings without them. It also stops the yo-yoing, the back and forth that keeps you hung up. It stops the confusion and it lets the cycle break. Like I just said, it means that where previously you were seeking out all of those positive feelings and emotions and reactions from this person, no contact means that you have no other option but to find these necessities somewhere else, hopefully in yourself first, but then eventually in other people, maybe eventually in a better partner. Making space like that, getting clear on the fact that holding onto this person is not what is best for you, I think really allows you to let peace into your life and to get control back over that situation.
快乐，并且在没有他们的情况下，你也能拥有亲密、充满爱意的感觉。它还制止了那种让你饱受折磨的、反反复复的拉锯战。它制止了混乱，并让这个循环得以打破。就像我刚才说的，这意味着过去你一直在向这个人寻求所有这些积极的感受、情绪和反应，而断联则意味着你别无选择，只能在其他地方寻找这些必需品，最好首先在你自己身上，然后最终在其他人身上，也许最终在一个更好的伴侣身上。腾出这样的空间，清楚地认识到抓住这个人不放并不是对你最好的选择，我认为这真的能让平静进入你的生活，并让你重新掌控那种局面。
and back over the kind of reactions and emotional reactions in particular that you can't stop yourself from having. You can't stop yourself from wanting this person. You can't undo the past, but you can control how you react to those circumstances and how much access this person continues to have and how much access you give yourself to them. So I think at the end of the day, like the main reason why no contact works is no contact works is because it breaks the neurological cycle of attachment but it also stops you from being confused it rids you of the temptation of going back to this person who you cannot be with for whatever reason and it lets you be kind of undistracted and undeterred it doesn't mean that you just continually elongate the
并重新掌控那些你无法阻止自己产生的反应，尤其是情绪反应。你无法阻止自己去想要这个人。你无法抹杀过去，但你可以控制自己如何对这些情况做出反应，以及这个人能继续拥有多少接触你的权限，以及你给了他们多少接触你的权限。所以我觉得归根结底，断联之所以有效，最主要的原因在于，它打破了依恋的神经学循环，但它也阻止了你的迷茫，它帮你戒除了想要回到这个人身边的诱惑——无论出于什么原因，你都不能和这个人在一起——它让你能够做到心无旁骛、坚定不移，这并不意味着你只是在不断地延长
detachment and the breakup process just because it is easy to be. to do it slower, but it means that it lasts longer and that eventually there will come a time where you do have to accept that your relationship is not what it once was and it is time to move on. So that is essentially my reasoning for why this is such an effective method. But how do we do it successfully? How do we stay strong and committed despite all of the things in us, all of the mental compulsions to reach out all of the desires to have this person back in our lives in some capacity. Well, we are going to talk about all of that and more after this short break.
脱离和分手的过程，仅仅因为这样做很容易。做得更慢一些，意味着这个过程会持续更久，最终总会有一天，你不得不接受这段感情已非复当年，是时候前进了。所以这就是我为什么认为这是一种如此有效的方法的根本原因。但是我们该如何成功做到这一点呢？尽管我们内心有着种种渴望联系的冲动、种种想要让这个人以某种身份回到我们生活中的欲望，我们要如何保持坚强和坚定呢？好吧，我们在稍后的简短休息之后，将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇异的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及构建抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（戳）小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会带你回顾过去，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也摆到台面上来了，所以。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变得只关乎输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你们觉得在人世间做一个好人很重要。你是一个好人，是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹就是因为想做一个好人。
Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在这里就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的、旨在证明真相的法庭之战。你伪造了这个特定的检测结果两次，欧文斯女士，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I think I've given you my most compelling argument for why you should go no contact, especially with an ex and some of the reasons and the science and the psychology that tells us why it works.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。所以我想我已经给出了我最引人注目的论点，说明为什么你应该断联，特别是对前任，以及一些解释为什么它管用的原因、科学和心理学。
But I think just saying it doesn't make it easy. A few years ago, I was seeing this person pretty casually for like four months, but they had a really like significant emotional impact of me. I think just because of the timing and everything that I was going through. And they were also just not somebody that I should have had in my life. They were not a kind person. And I eventually realized that it was a pretty terrible situation. I needed to cut him off. But the number of times I blocked and deleted his.
但我觉得光是嘴上说说并不能让事情变得简单。几年前，我曾与这个人非常随性地交往了大约四个月，但他们对我产生了非常巨大的情感影响。我想仅仅是因为当时的时机以及我正在经历的一切。而且他们也不是那种我应该留在生命里的人。他们不是一个善良的人。我最终意识到那是一个相当糟糕的局面。我需要切断与他的联系。但是我无数次地屏蔽并删除了他的
number and then would unblock him or would reply to his messages on Instagram wherever you would have thought that nothing had changed and it took me i think two to three whole months to really finally quit that situation and to really go cold turkey so that is just one of the situations where I've really applied this rule obviously not very well but I do have some advice that I've learned from my failures, I guess, not my failures. I have some advice that I've learned from my missteps and from my learning experience. So here are five, I think of my best tips and principles for successful no contact. Firstly, try just 21 days of no contact first, straight after a breakup, before going all in.
号码，然后又取消屏蔽，或者在Instagram或其他任何地方回复他的消息，你本会以为一切都没有改变。我大概花了整整两到三个月的时间，才真正彻底结束那种局面，真正做到彻底斩断。所以这只是我真正应用这条规则的情况之一，显然做得不是很好，但我确实有一些从失败中学到的经验——我想，不是失败。我有一些从错误和学习经历中学到的建议。所以这里有五个我认为是关于成功断联的最佳技巧和原则。首先，在刚分手后，先尝试仅仅21天的断联，然后再全力以赴。
I think this gives us an adjustment period to really reflect. on what we want going forward, and just taking that three weeks to get an immediate distance to really process our emotions. I think it's also important because it gives us space before we do something impulsive that we'll regret. Sometimes, you know, when we're in that highly emotional and volatile state, sometimes, you know, we don't always do what is right. Sometimes we are not able to put in the boundaries that we know what we are going to need later on. Sometimes it is messy and confusing and we get back together with them and then we break up with them again. Giving yourself that three weeks of distance straight after an incredibly emotionally intense situation lets you get clear. And for practical
我认为这给了我们一个适应期，去真正反思我们对未来的期望，并且花这三个星期来获得即时的距离，以真正处理我们的情绪。我认为这也很重要，因为它在我们在冲动行事并追悔莫及之前，为我们留出了空间。有时，你知道的，当我们处于那种高度情绪化和不稳定的状态时，有时，你知道的，我们并不总是能做正确的事。有时我们无法设立我们知道自己以后会需要的界限。有时情况会变得混乱而困惑，我们和他们复合了，然后又再次分手。在经历了一个极其情绪化的紧张局面后，给自己三周的距离，能让你思路清晰。而且从实际
reasons, right, like it's only three weeks. You guys can come back together and have a conversation. You might have like items or things to give back, ground rules to apply. But you've still given yourself like a bit of a head start. And you can still see that, you know, you can live without them. that three weeks, you can do another three weeks. You have breathing room and you have, yeah, I guess practice and skill to see that this is important and to see that you can live on your own and you can live without that connection. Secondly, treat no contact as a challenge. And when you are really struggling, as we all do, just go for one more hour, go for one more minute, even when it's really hard. I think that saying goes, it's something like you can do, you can do anything for 30 seconds.
原因来看，对吧，这只有三个星期。你们还是可以复合并进行对话的。你们可能还有一些物品或东西需要归还，需要适用一些基本原则。但你仍然为自己争取到了一个领先优势。你仍然可以看到，你知道的，没有他们你也能生活。撑过了那三个星期，你就可以再撑三个星期。你有了喘息的空间，并且是的，我想你也有了练习和技能，去看到这是多么重要，看到你可以独立生活，没有那种联系也能活下去。其次，把断联当作一个挑战。当你在苦苦挣扎时——我们大家都会经历这个过程——哪怕再坚持一个小时，再坚持一分钟，哪怕事情真的很难。我想那句俗语是这么说的，大概意思就是你可以做到，任何事情你都可以坚持30秒。
When that temptation to reach out to them is really overpowering, just focus on the 30 seconds in front of you and then the next 30 and then the next 30 before like the craving and the urge dissipates. The other piece of advice I have that's related to this is to download a sobriety app. Now, I know this sounds so strange, but there are apps out there that track your progress when it comes to quitting alcohol, quitting drugs, quitting substances. We can also use that for people. It keeps you focused on the time you have already put into removing yourself. It keeps you focused on the progress that you are making that you don't want to undo in a moment of weakness. And it really, I think, makes it feel more like.
当想要联系他们的诱惑力大到无法抗拒时，只需专注于眼前的30秒，然后是下一个30秒，再下一个30秒，直到这种渴望和冲动消散。我给出的另一个与之相关的建议是下载一个戒瘾应用程序。现在，我知道这听起来很奇怪，但市面上确实有一些应用程序，可以追踪你在戒酒、戒毒、戒除物质成瘾方面的进展。我们也可以把这招用在人际关系上。它能让你专注于你已经投入到将自己抽离出来的那些时间。它能让你专注于你所取得的进展，让你不想在软弱的时刻前功尽弃。而且我认为，它真的能让这一切感觉更像是一个
like a challenge, then a chore, eventually as well. Speaking from experience, it's something that you just don't even check. You don't even care. And I think that moment when you're like, oh, I'm not looking at the minutes that we spent apart ticking by. I'm not looking at the hours we haven't spoken, you know, floating into the ether. I don't care anymore. That is when you know that you've healed.
挑战，而不是一件苦差事，最终也是如此。以我个人的经验来说，这甚至会变成一件你根本不会去查看的事情。你甚至根本不在乎了。我想，当你发现“哦，我不再去盯着我们分开的分钟数一秒秒流逝了，我不再去关注我们没有说话的小时数慢慢消散了，我不在乎了”的那一刻，就是你知道自己已经痊愈的时刻。
I know that right now the possibility of that reality, the possibility of no longer even caring about what that person is doing or who they're with, you know, no longer being able to hear from them or touch them. Right now that reality seems really devastating. But I think with time, that sting will lessen. That doesn't necessarily mean that this process will be linear. I think for anybody who has, you know, been through a breakup, been through a friendship breakup or a family estrangement, process is not linear.
我知道现在那种现实的可能性——不再在乎那个家伙在做什么、和谁在一起，你知道的，不再能听到他们的声音或触碰他们——那种现实现在听起来确实令人心碎。但我想随着时间的推移，那种刺痛会减轻。这并不一定意味着这个过程会是线性的。我想对于任何经历过分手、经历过友情破裂或家庭疏离的人来说，这个过程绝不是线性的。
each day it's not promised that it's going to be better than the last. I think that's a fact of life is that grief does not know any timeline but its own. However, I want you to remember that it is totally normal for that to be the case. It is totally normal to have a few weeks where you feel amazing and you feel great and then just a day of just despair and grief and tears, even when you've been doing so well. So this brings me to my next tip. Don't be afraid of memory flare-ups and don't let them undo your progress. Just because you're still thinking about them after going no contact doesn't mean you are
每一天并不保证都会比前一天更好。我认为生活的一个事实就是，悲伤不遵循任何时间表，它只遵循它自己的节奏。然而，我希望你记住，这种情况完全是正常的。有那么几周你感觉好极了、状态棒极了，然后紧接着就迎来了一个充满绝望、悲伤和眼泪的日子，哪怕你之前一直做得很好，这也是完全正常的。所以这就带出了我的下一个建议。不要害怕记忆的突然涌现，也不要让它们毁了你的进展。仅仅因为你在断联后还在想着他们，并不意味着你
failing and it definitely doesn't mean it's not working. Just because you find yourself fantasizing or daydreaming about the past doesn't mean that you should revisit it. I want you to remember that. I think we all know that feeling of having like an eerily weird dream about an X and thinking that there is some deeper meaning, but there isn't. This is just your brain processing information and processing important memories. So there's a concept that I like to bring up when people talk to me about this.
正在失败，这绝对不意味着断联没有效果。仅仅因为你发现自己在对过去进行幻想或白日梦，并不意味着你应该重温过去。我希望你记住这一点。我想我们都有过这样的感觉：做一个关于前任的诡异离奇的梦，然后以为里面有什么更深层的含义，但其实并没有。这只是你的大脑在处理信息和处理重要的记忆。所以当人们跟我聊起这个时，我喜欢提出这样一个概念。
You know, I had someone actually messaged me the other day and she was like, you know, it's been eight months since I've gone no contact and I've just randomly, in the last couple weeks, I cannot stop reliving things. I cannot stop thinking about her. So this is a phenomenon known as mind pops. And it's super strange. Essentially what happens is that you'll be going about your day, you're feeling amazing,
你知道的，前几天确实有人给我发信息说：“你知道的，我已经断联八个月了，但在过去几周里，我莫名其妙地无法停止回忆各种事情。我无法停止想她。”所以这是一种被称为“心灵突显”（mind pops）的现象。而且这超级奇怪。本质上发生的情况是，你正在过着你的一天，你感觉棒极了，
and then this random memory or image will suddenly pop into your head for no specific reason, almost like a flashback. Now there was an article written about this almost 10, oh my gosh 12 years ago it was written in 2012 so it was written by scientific America and the reason that this happens is not because you know it's a sign that somebody else is thinking about you it's not because your brain knows something that you don't or that it's fate or destiny it's actually just a part of our brain kind of cleaning out the filing cabinet it's part of our brain just filtering through our semantic or autobiographical memories as it needs
然后这个随机的记忆或画面就会毫无特定原因地突然闯入你的脑海，几乎就像闪回一样。现在，一篇关于这个的文章在差不多10年前——哦天哪，是12年前，写于2012年——被《科学美国人》（Scientific American）杂志发表了。发生这种情况的原因并不是因为，你知道的，这是别人在想你的征兆，不是因为你的大脑知道一些你不知道的事情，也不是因为这是天意或命运，它其实只是我们大脑在清理文件柜的一部分。这只是我们大脑根据需要对我们的语义或自传体记忆进行筛选的一部分。
to do. You know, our brains are constantly working and going and they're shooting energy and impulses across millions of neural connections. Sometimes it's, you know, these connections, sometimes these electrical impulses are going to accidentally take the wrong road and they're going to revisit something unexpected. That is normal. It's also a lot more common around like significant dates. So if it's a birthday or Valentine's Day or a former anniversary, it's also all the more common in what we know as the anniversary effect. So our recollection of painful or hard memories, our sense of longing, it does typically increase around significant dates and significant moments.
你知道的，我们的大脑一直在运作、运转，它们在数百万个神经连接之间发射能量和冲动。有时，你知道的，这些连接、有时这些电脉冲会不小心走错路，然后重新温习一些意料之外的事情。这是正常的。在重要日子前后，这种情况也更为常见。所以如果是一个生日、情人节或曾经的纪念日，在所谓的“周年纪念效应”中，这种情况也更加普遍。因此，我们对痛苦或艰难记忆的回忆、我们的渴望感，通常确实会在重要的日子和重要的时刻增加。
I think this is especially the case like around Christmas is one that people talk to me about or around birthdays where you're like, oh, last year I was with this person and I felt really, really loved and this year I'm not. and it just brings back a lot of the pain. I don't want you to see that as a reason that you are failing. I don't want you to think that that means you're losing progress. It is actually a super, super, super normal part of this journey. I really promise you.
我认为这种情况尤其体现在圣诞节前后——这是人们经常跟我聊到的一个日子——或者在生日前后，你会想：“哦，去年我和这个人在一起，我感到了真正被爱，而今年我没有。”这只会带回很多痛苦。我不希望你把这看作是你正在失败的理由。我不希望你认为这意味着你在失去进展。这实际上是这段旅程中一个超级、超级、超级正常的组成部分。我真的向你保证。
So my fourth tip is to share with your friends. Share your commitment to go no contact or to maintain your no contact with people around who you trust and who you know, about you because they will help you stay accountable. This is kind of a rule of thumb if you wouldn't tell your friends about something. So if you wouldn't tell them that you've, you know, cheekily replied to somebody's story or that you, you know, emailed them or that you had an accidental run in with them. Like if you wouldn't tell them that, it's probably not the thing that you should be doing. It is probably the wrong decision. So when you do have those urges
所以我的第四个建议是与你的朋友分享。与你信任的、了解你的人分享你断联的承诺或保持断联的决心，因为他们会帮助你保持责任感。这有点像一条经验法则：如果你不会把某件事告诉你的朋友。所以如果你不会告诉他们你，你知道的，俏皮地回复了某个人的动态，或者你，你知道的，给他们发了电子邮件，或者你不小心跟他们偶遇了。就像如果你不会把这些告诉他们，这可能就不是你应该做的事情。这很可能是错误的决定。所以当你确实有了那些
to reach out because we will have them text and talk to your friends instead. So I had a friend who actually changed my name in her phone to her ex's name when she wanted to text him and she would like message me all the things that she would want to say like, I'm so upset that you hurt me, you've really let me down but I want to give you another chance. She would send that to me and I would like reply as him and be super rational and I would say what I knew she needed to hear, not what she wanted to hear, but what if I imagine what what he would say that would convince her that that was a bad decision. And it worked. It sounds super bizarre, but it worked. Community, I think, is also just a valuable antidote to the general
想要联系的冲动时——因为我们都会有这种冲动——那就转而给你的朋友发短信和聊天吧。我有一个朋友，当她想给他发信息时，她实际上把她手机里我的名字改成了她前任的名字，然后她会把所有她想说的话发信息给我，比如：“我很生气的你伤害了我，你真的让我失望了，但我还想再给你一次机会。”她会把这些发给我，而我会扮演他进行回复，表现得超级理智，我会说出我知道她需要听的话，而不是她想听的话，但如果我设想他会说些什么来让她确信那是个糟糕的决定的话，我就会那样说。这管用。这听起来超级离奇，但它确实管用。我认为，社群也是对抗我们可能经历的普遍
loneliness we may experience. When we are so used to talking to our ex, it is a compulsion, it is a habit, it can feel like a whole has been left in our life. Who are we going to share our everyday thoughts with? Who are we going to, you know, share our successes and our failures with? Who's going to celebrate us. Who is going to care about that small thing that, you know, we saw on the bus or that happened at work? Your friends will. Tell them. They want to hear from you. That is a way of making your relationship as strong as the one that you shared with this other person, communication and vulnerability and letting them help you. Finally, my final tip for making no contact work, make the fortress impenetrable.
孤独感的一种宝贵的解药。当我们太习惯于和前任聊天时，这是一种强迫行为，是一种习惯，它会让人觉得生活中留下了一个空洞。我们要和谁分享我们的日常想法呢？我们要和谁，你知道的，分享我们的成功与失败呢？谁来为我们庆祝？谁会在乎我们在公交车上看到的或者在工作发生的那件小事呢？你的朋友会的。告诉他们。他们很想听到你的消息。这是让你们的关系变得和你们与另一个人分享的关系一样坚固的一种方式——通过沟通、脆弱性并让他们帮助你。最后，我关于让断联发挥作用的最后一个建议：把堡垒打造得坚不可摧。
leave no passage unblocked. There is no way for them to get in. Because if you leave a secret door open that only you know about, you are giving yourself the option to reach back out. You are creating also the false promise that if they wanted to get in touch with you, they could. And that is not the commitment that we are looking for. That is not being in 100%.
不留任何未被封锁的通道。不给他们留任何进来的途径。因为如果你留了一扇只有你自己知道的秘密门，你就是在给自己留出重新联系的选项。你也在制造一个虚假的承诺，即如果他们想联系你，他们是可以做到的。而这并不是我们所追求的承诺。那并不是100%的投入。
Instagram, Facebook, email text, cut them all off. And if they do somehow find a way to reach out to you, have something prepared to say. So I'm going to quote this article by the coach Matthew Hussie because I love what he had to say about this in a recent article. When somebody reaches back out, I think that is the time that it is the hardest because it's like they're right there. It's like putting a bowl of candy in front of a kid and saying don't touch it, even though that's all the time. they want to do. That is all you want to do right now. The thing you most want in the world is to hear from that person because hearing for them is going to reignite so much that you actually did enjoy and that you are nostalgic about when it comes to your relationship. So it is very much like
Instagram、Facebook、电子邮件、短信，把他们全部切断。如果他们真的通过某种方式找到了联系你的方法，提前准备好要说的话。所以我要引用教练马修·胡西（Matthew Hussie）在最近一篇文章中的话，因为我太喜欢他在一篇近期文章中关于这个问题的看法了。当某人重新联系你时，我认为那是事情最艰难的时刻，因为感觉他们就在那里。这就像把一碗糖果放在一个孩子面前并告诉他不要碰一样，尽管这正是他们
reopening an old wound. And then I think it just sets, it's just like a domino effect. Once you reply to one message being like, yeah, hey, how are you? Instead of just ignoring it or instead of being like hi actually i'm not looking to have any further communication with you if you don't do that immediately it snowballs it might just be a few messages it might last an entire day it might be the rekindling of a relationship that you already know was not meant to be so have something planned that you are going to say in response to those situations find something a specific affirmation or a mantra or whatever, some kind of motivation that's going to, you know, keep you focused on why this is important, why you wanted to do this in the first place.
一直想做的事。这也是你现在最想做的事。你在世上最想做的事情就是听到那个人的消息，因为听到他们的消息会重新点燃那么多你确实很享受、并且对你们的关系怀念不已的东西。所以这非常像是
Maybe it is, you know, I don't want to have contact with this person because I know that by doing that I will leave space for somebody better to come into my life. Maybe it is, you know, eventually this relationship is going to have to fade. I would rather it starts now that in three months, six months a year, whatever it is that is keeping you motivated, stay on it. Stay focused. I'm sending you so much a love and strength because I know this is really hard. This person probably meant so much to you. They probably were somebody that you really cared about. And nobody goes into the start of a relationship with anybody, romantic, platonic, anything, imagining the ending. And so when we do find ourselves there, it just seems that any way
重新撕开一道旧伤口。然后我认为这只会引发多米诺骨牌效应。一旦你回复了一条消息，说“噢，嘿，你好吗”，而不是直接忽略它，或者而不是说“嗨，实际上我不想再和你进行任何进一步的交流”——如果你不立即这样做，它就会像滚雪球一样扩大。可能只是几条消息，可能会持续整整一天，可能会重燃一段你心里明明知道并不属于你的感情。所以，为应对这些情况提前计划好你要说的话，找到一个特定的肯定语句、一句箴言，或者别的什么，某种能够让你专注于“为什么这很重要”、“为什么你一开始就想这么做”的动力。
to cope is something that we have to try. And I do think that this is one of the better ways. This is one of the healthier, more sustainable ways of finding peace, finding closure, taking your life back for yourself. So there is not that cloud lingering over your head of what if, or what next, or is there a future for us? You have closed that door for good. You're not opening it again. As hard as that might be, it will get easier. I promise you it will get easier and you will find somebody better and you will find somebody who you never have to consider this possibility with. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode. I really do hope that you enjoyed and I'm sure that if you've listened this far, you're probably really going through it right now. So I really,
也许是，你知道的，“我不想和这个人保持联系，因为我知道这样做会为更好的人走进我的生活腾出空间”。也许是，你知道的，“这段感情最终终将消逝。我宁愿它现在就开始，而不是在三个月、六个月、一年之后”——无论是什么在激励着你，坚持下去。保持专注。我向你发送满满的爱和力量，因为我知道这真的很不容易。这个人对你来说可能意义重大。他们很可能曾是你非常在乎的人。没有人会在与任何人——无论是浪漫的、柏拉图式的还是任何关系的开始时——去想象它的结局。所以当我们发现自己处于那种境地时，任何应对的方式
really empathize with you and I sympathize for you. It is tough. Do not let yourself feel any differently. And I'm sending lots of love. It's going to be okay. Make sure that if you enjoyed this episode or if there's somebody who you know might relate to this, send it to them. Send them a link. It might be able to help them out. Make sure that you leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now, and that you are following along so that you never miss a new episode. And, And as I mentioned at the start, we do have our new series of notebooks live now on the website. Make sure you check it out. Make sure you get your hands on it.
似乎都是我们不得不尝试的办法。而且我确实认为这是更好的方法之一。这是寻找平静、寻找解脱、为自己夺回生活的更健康、更可持续的方法之一。这样就不会有一团乌云盘旋在你的头顶，让你去想“如果”或者“接下来会怎样”，或者“我们之间还有未来吗”。你已经彻底关上了那扇门。你不会再把它打开了。尽管这可能很难，但它会变得更容易。我向你保证，它会变得更容易，你会找到更好的人，你会找到一个你永远不必考虑这种可能性的人。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。我真的希望你们会喜欢，而且我确信如果你听到了这里，你现在可能真的正经历着艰难的时刻。所以我真的、
If you're looking for a place to write your deepest, darker secrets, I think that might just be it. That might just be where you can do it. Until next time, thank you for listening. Be kind. Be gentle with yourself. And we will talk soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
真的对你感同身受，我为你感到同情。这很艰难。不要让自己有任何不同的感受。我送上许多爱。一切都会好起来的。如果你喜欢这一集，或者你知道有人可能会对此感同身受，请把它发给他们。发给他们一个链接。这或许能帮到他们。确保你在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评，并保持关注，这样你就永远不会错过新的一集。而且，正如我在开头提到的，我们的全新系列笔记本现已在网站上上线。一定要去看看。确保你买到它。
84 is big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a year unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it
如果你正在寻找一个地方来写下你最深、最黑暗的秘密，我想那可能就是个好地方。那可能就是你能做到这一点的地方。下次见，谢谢收听。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会聊。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和而言是一个巨大的时刻。
With our friends Fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill On the 80s It was a wild year I don't think There's a more important
84年对我来说意义重大 我是萨姆·杰克 和我是一直是亚历克斯·英格利希 每在一集中 我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么 并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的
year for black people Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening And learn the hard way
和我们的朋友们 还有同为喜剧演员的同行 以及最喜欢的作家们 比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔 谈论80年代 那是一个疯狂的年份 我认为
with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast,
对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了 在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客上收听《Look Back at It》 或在你获取播客的任何地方 嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你正在收听的是《Learn the Hard Way》
or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sondland's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。多少男人身披铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不容小觑的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客上收听《Learn the Hard Way》，
Michael Ranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As this season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
或在你获取播客的任何地方。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控怀有双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，欧文斯女士，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。